before we begin since this is a BBC
owned property I feel the need to point
out that the news armor the BBC has a
continuing issue with transphobic
leanings in its news coverage you can
find in a pinned comment below various
videos from both myself and other
YouTubers covering this issue and while
I understand that the Doctor Who
creative team is not responsible for
this I will continue to point this out
for as long as it remains a consistent
issue thank you
what
[Music]
David Tennant is back we knew that was
happening what was speculated about but
was not certain that we now know is that
he's the 14th doctor now
so I kind of touched on this a little
bit in my review of the power of the
doctor and I kind of just breezed over
the fact that on paper and I have in the
past actually said that I think this is
a terrible idea to have the doctor
regenerate literally into an old actor
but I was a lot more okay with it than I
expected to be that is not without
caveats and I kind of want to dive into
that a little bit more here firstly I
suppose a little history as I said I've
gone on record saying that this is a
terrible idea and I'm not even
necessarily going to walk that back I do
think it is an idea that is very fraught
and even if this is ultimately well
executed I think there are going to be
some negative Ripple effects of having
made this decision that is just not
gonna be in the best interest of the
health of the show or the fandom overall
but
I don't think it's going to be as much
of a death blow as I was certain back
when I said the show should never ever
do this and that is what I said I
literally had a video that was four
things Doctor Who should never do this I
think I think this was even my top one
so yeah I've been pretty adamant about
this in the past and I didn't talk about
it as a possibility leading up to the
power of the doctor because honestly as
much as I saw other people speculating
that she was going to literally
regenerate into tenant
I didn't believe it I didn't think that
that was going to happen and so I didn't
want to indulge the idea because I knew
that for all the people who just went oh
that's a neat rumor I heard about that
or people who were just excited because
they really liked tenant there were also
people who really basically just wanted
to act like see this is an emission of
the failure of Whitaker they literally
had her regenerated into a much better
doctor see we were right she was never
my doctor and I just don't want to
engage with those people anymore but
um that's now what has happened so yeah
I do need to deal with it why don't I
back up and talk about what my issues
have been with the general core concept
of bringing back an old doctor firstly I
feel like it's the kind of move that
feels very retrograde it feels
reactionary and it feels like well
just feels a bit wanky
it feels like something that a show that
is more interested in its past Glory
than charting A New Path would do it's
actually a fairly sizable part of why it
I didn't have a lot of interest in a lot
of what Star Trek was doing for a while
because for decades actually after
Voyager everything was either a reboot
or sat in an earlier part in the
timeline the franchise refused to move
forward it was only interested in
looking back in some way shape or form
and I just don't really have a lot of
interest in that now like I readily
admit sometimes your best days are
behind you sometimes charting the Future
Path will not get it to be as good as it
was but I just think it's creatively
healthier for a property to continue to
move forward than to start to become
masturbatory in this sort of oh remember
the Glory Days let's bring that back and
like Doctor Who is already susceptible
to that in certain ways in terms of
bringing back old villains or even
bringing back
um old doctors for multi-doctor style
stuff that's already in there I didn't
want to see that to become so ingrained
that we literally brought back an old
doctor and the other thing is that it's
the kind of thing and this is actually
part of the reason why I was very
nervous going into the Multiverse with
Marvel and I'm pretty confident Marvel
is not going to go there at all with
this but one of the reasons I was really
terrified of that idea was like oh crap
are they going to use that to bring back
Dead characters are we gonna get like a
a new Tony Stark even if it's not Robert
Downey Jr because oh this one's From
Another Universe or even if they don't
fans are going to ask them to do that to
bring back things that the franchise
moved on from because now there is a
mechanism by which to do that and
thankfully that hasn't happened with the
MCU but I'm they're now breaking that
seal with Doctor Who and the precedent
has been set we can go back to an old
doctor and I don't like that that
precedent has been said that precedent
has been hinted at previously The Day of
the Doctor and Tom Baker's appearance
but it was only hinted there to actually
do it to actually have the audience
watch
the doctor becomes someone who has
already been in the part before
that just feels like it invites
all the more demanding and often times
toxic infighting and screaming and
demands from some aspects of the Doctor
Who fandom
because they're going to point to this
and go you gave us what we wanted once
now we want to demand more or after
tenant leaves and if they don't like
shurikatua maybe some of these people
are going to start shouting we'll bring
back Matt Smith we know you can now so I
just don't like that in terms of its
impact on the fandom and how it impacts
the way they think about this property
and the way they approach it I just
don't think it's I don't think it's
healthy I don't think it's healthy for
the state of a property overall and I
still hold to most of that
and yet
and yet
I am not really angry right now
I'm not gonna say it's all good and it's
going to be great I don't know that what
I'm in right now is something of a
holding pattern which is that
I can see given some of the things we
have set up and some of the pieces that
are in place and some of the ways this
is being approached
how Russell T Davis May well have found
a way to do what I still think is a very
bad idea
in a way that I couldn't think to do it
that actually resolves a lot of my
issues and honestly first of all I love
when that happens
I love when a show of film series a
comic book some property is able to take
something that I look at and go that's a
really bad idea and make something
amazing with it whether it's you know at
a basic core concept level something
like The Lego Movie that's a terror idea
that's that's a really good movie or
whether it be something like what she
were on the princesses of power was able
to do with its Fifth Season I said prior
to that they cannot try and redeem Catra
it's not gonna work like it's gonna be
really damaging as a message if they try
but it succeeded because they went at it
in a way that I just assumed they
wouldn't do I assumed they would try and
redeem her in like a moment like she's
made the switch no they instead
dedicated a massive swath of time and
huge chunks of the fifth season into
showing how much work was involved in
that I'm sorry I got angry it's
something I'm working on oh you are yes
now can you please
yes basically proving that they were
smarter than me
I want writers who are smarter than me
like I have a slightly inflated opinion
of my own intelligence but I want
writers who will think of stuff I didn't
think of especially if they can use
those ideas to take an idea that I don't
think could possibly work and make it
work in ways I couldn't imagine I love
that and I don't know for certain if
that's what's going to happen with
tenant but I see the pieces where it
could here's what I mean about that
first is right off the bat this
regeneration is established immediately
as weird
an anomalous
and like something's wrong
a lot of people have decided to sort of
Riff and latch on to the idea of the
doctor's clothing regenerating I don't
have too much thought on that some
people will say well that actually
happened with the first regeneration
from the first doctor into the second
like production wisest because it was
the first generation that didn't really
hadn't fully figured out how it worked
yet
um there are others who think it's like
an error and or what have you but like I
think it's on purpose
and I think it actually means something
not like a deep Let's Get Out The
Conspiracy board meeting but I think
it's one more thing that is meant to add
to the fact that something is off and
wrong and this is not what should have
happened so the fact that the clothes
regenerate as well the fact that the
outfit is not a match for any outfit
we've seen tented in before that it's
incredibly reminiscent of tenants
outfits during his tenure but it's not a
match it's not the same
it's a coat and a vest the tie is not a
tie he ever wore before it's not the
same look
it's the same general thing but the
specifics aren't quite right and then
there's of course tenant's actual
reaction
sort of shock confusion
possibly even borderline Panic at
realizing what face he has again
this is not supposed to happen
so that's the first thing that does a
bit to alleviate my concerns about this
setting a precedent because if this is
approached and everything about how it
is shot and presented in its initial
form as we saw in power of the doctor
that all leans towards the idea that
this is not normal so if we take this
thing and establish it as a massive
anomaly as something that should not
have happened and something that is not
ever supposed to happen then that
removes the narrative idea that oh well
we can just do that again yep but no it
was completely established as anomalous
before so no you can't just do it
whenever now that's not to say that it's
going to be like impossible for some
other writer or even Davis himself to
theoretically come up with a reason that
it could happen again it's not like it
completely locks it off but it does mean
that it's not something that can be done
casually if you're ever going to try and
do this again you're going to have to
put work in and that can be enough to
dissuade this for from being done
loosey-goosey or from the uh from the
audience and the fans from for asking
for it to be done just because they want
it so that's already a good start next
up is the fact that we already know this
is a limited run
tenant is getting three specials next
year in 2023 and they have already
announced who the doctor after him is
because we know about we know about
shooting before we knew that tenant was
coming back so that also helps because
it's again making it making it clear and
in the framing this is something special
this is limited this is not the norm or
The New Normal this is something that we
are doing kind of as a one-off and we
are already telling you what's coming
after like yes this will be fun we'll
have these specials and then you have
this new thing to look forward to so
they've already managed to sidestep the
issue of tenant completely overshadowing
whoever comes after him partly because
they announced who was coming after him
before we even knew this that in
hindsight especially was an incredibly
smart and Savvy thing to do to get
people excited about shudigatwa before
you bring in tenant because if you if
they found out about tenant first if
that have either been announced first or
leaked first or whatever if we had known
for a certainty if we had seen the the
photographs of him on set with the
Tardis with Donna with wilf before
shootikats was casting was announced
that would have been a disaster for the
future of the show after these specials
because people would have been all
excited like oh he's coming back how
long will we have him it'll be great and
then to be like no you're only getting
in three specials that could have
brought resentment instead because they
pitched shurigatwa first told us that's
who's next now this is a special little
treat before the thing we were already
promised that was really smart and would
have been really easy to mess up just by
putting those reveals in the wrong order
so again kind of like what I talked
about in the last video when I talked
about the logo and the Disney plus and
sort of the initial marketing we're
starting to see it's well thought out
it's well planned and I say that even
acknowledging that the shurigatwa
announcement felt like it was trying to
get ahead of a leak it felt rushed
because it basically was just announced
and dropped in answers to questions on a
red carpet there wasn't like a
production announcement video like there
was with Whitaker or like a big reveal
like there was with Capaldi or even like
a little specially filmed thing like
there was with Matt Smith so even though
it felt like they threw together the
announcement very hurriedly because they
were expecting Elite to come out they
still knew to announce that first that's
big that matters because I don't doubt
tenant was probably already signed on
um by the time that that announcement
was made I think he probably would have
had to have been so there's a level of
care that I'm seeing how this is being
handled so far that helps because my
biggest concern about bringing back an
old doctor is that it feels careless
this is a careless idea being done
with a lot of care care that I just kind
of assumed would never be applied to
this concept so that all helps a lot now
despite all the praise I've just said I
did say I'm kind of in a holding pattern
on my full feelings because it's going
to very much depend
on what the story actually is and how
this version of the doctor is actually
presented and approached and this is
where I'm going to bring in the fact
that Russell T Davis and a comment
actually called the called shirigapwa
the 15th doctor which would make this
Incarnation the 14th doctor which means
David Tennant is now the Tenth Doctor
and the 14th doctor and at present I
don't know how I feel about that
my Liker dislike for that idea is
completely conditional on what happens
in the specials because if in terms of
characterization and in terms of how he
behaves what he says if everything about
him
is just an extension of the 10th doctor
it's just more of exactly who that was
that's going to annoy me calling him the
14th because you're taking one doctor
and injecting him across multiple
regenerations and
even if narratively the stories were
giving his second go a distinct
numbering would bother me
but
if
there is some difference in the
characterization if there is some
commentary and some introspection about
what this means and how he reacts and
responds to it in a way that is I have
no doubt reminiscent of but also
distinct from the Tenth Doctor
then I'll be okay with thinking of this
as an independent entity and again
that's completely conditional what we're
going to get but I am provisionally
hopeful
because you know what that
um outfit not quite matching what he had
before signals to me aside from
emphasizing sort of the anomalous nature
that to me feels like an early warning
this is not going to be exactly how you
remember him
I'm kind of hoping that what they're
going to do is basically pull a Final
Fantasy VII remake which is an odd
comparison for me to make because if you
saw my review of that game over in the
break room of Geeks I actually really
didn't like it but that didn't have to
do with the narrative that was a
mechanical dislike for the game but if
you don't know Final Fantasy VII remake
did something that was kind of divisive
especially when it first released
because it did largely follow the plot
of the original Final Fantasy VII game
but there were definite and distinct
narrative differences new things were
being added in and in fact the changes
to aspects of the narrative was part of
the built-in story
that's kind of what I'm hoping Davis is
doing and that's what I'm hoping that
this outfit not fully matching is
signaling it's like yes at first glance
it's the same thing but the closer you
look
wait it's not though and I hope that
that is a concept and a feel that gets
expanded on and is the heart of these
specials like I'm sure they'll also tell
entertaining stories in their own right
but thematically
I kind of want I might even need that to
be if not the primary theme a very
distinct and clear one in this because
Russell is not above
um making commentary on fandom and the
state of the show I mean that's actually
what love and monsters is it didn't
really work in love and monsters but
like he's done that kind of thing before
and I could see this becoming something
of a meta commentary on
basically you can't go back again you
can try
but it's not going to quite be the same
and maybe we should just move on will
that be the distinct actual message I
don't know I don't know it might be it
might not be but that's where I'm hoping
he's leaning and right now what I'm
seeing about how this is being presented
gives me hope
that that's where he's going and so as a
result I am shockingly positive on an
idea that on premise I hate
and so here we are
those are my feelings on Jody Whitaker
regenerating into David Tennant
what do you think about this what do you
think about what I've said the idea in
general whatever your thoughts are
drop something down in the comments
let's talk about it there are a ton of
new subscribers in I'm very glad to have
you here I definitely want to hear from
you folks as well also you know consider
supporting the patreon if you don't
already that's what enables me to do
this as my living into talk to you folks
as frequently as I do both here and in
the break room of Geeks but uh even if
you can't support me that way like share
subscribe those help too
but what I really want you to remember
is you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
all right time to thank my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Zubin
lafolla Tarak the theme that goes joint
in the anime Oliver B Melinda Walters e
mudelki Leo the Boyd toy lowly Becky
Sparks for nobelax the poodle Zack
Bookworm Tracy scrabot angry Casper Adam
RDL Taylor Shayla gourlay Brendan Larose
and TT thank you for your support if you
want to hear me try and say your name
while this little guy tries to chew on
my earrings well you can check out the
patreon or the support tears that get
you a shout out
thanks so much you are a pain in my butt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]